Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Nein, nein.
Eigentlich kann man jetzt so ein bisschen schon fast anfangen.
Du merkst, mir ist das Stichwort entfallen.
Das waren die Browsertechnologien.
Technologie war das Wort, ganz genau.
Genau, also die ganzen Disco-Features mit irgendwie Web 2.0 und Interaktion.
Erstmal Web 1.0.
Erstmal Web 1.0? Okay, dann war's.
Ganz langsam. Ja, also irgendwie ein Stichwort haben wir noch vergessen zu erwähnen, das ist das W3C. Was heißt denn das ausgesprochen?
World Wide Web Konsortium, also W3 für dreimal W, World Wide Web Konsortium.
Ja, stimmt, genau. Ja, und die gab es auch schon relativ früh in der Geschichte des Webbs, und die waren eigentlich die, die sozusagen die Standards, die die Browser implementieren, um so eine Webseite anzuzeigen, vorgegeben haben. Internet Explorer haben wir schon gesagt, der war dann ein bisschen besser in der Implementation dieser Vorgaben. Netscape hat so gesagt, ach, nö, wir wollen jetzt irgendwie andere Sachen einbauen, das ist jetzt uns zu langweilig, was das W3C uns vorschlägt. Und da gab es sozusagen diese Schere. Und irgendwie, ab Firefox könnte man fast so sagen, ging es dann wieder darum, doch jetzt mal diese Webstandards enger zu verfolgen und sie richtig zu implementieren, weil, nämlich davor gab es ja auch noch die Phase, wo auf so einer Webseite immer stand, diese Seite kann am besten mit Internet Explorer, Internet Explorer angeschaut werden oder mit Netzgeb-Navigator, das daran lag, dass eben Netzgeb das implementiert hat, Internet Explorer, ein bisschen Standards, aber ein bisschen auch eigene Sachen. Und du konntest halt keine Seite für beide bauen oder nur unter extrem großem Aufwand. So und dann bei Firefox ging es halt darum, nicht nur Open Source, wir entwickeln zusammen Browser, sondern wir machen jetzt auch Webstandards, weil Webstandards sind gut. Wir kümmern uns jetzt mal darum, dass alle Seiten auf beiden Browsern oder auf allen Browsern gleich aussehen. So und dann ging es halt los. Dann als erstes hier Cascading Style Sheets, also was auch Mozilla schon konnte, aber dann bei Firefox auch erst so richtig wieder weiterverfolgt wurde. Das war sozusagen die erste große, neue Technologie, die dann dazu geführt hat, dass Webseiten auf einmal viel, viel hübscher aussehen. Also man erinnert sich ja auch echt mit grauen, also wenn man das Web Archive, kennst du übrigens das Web Archive? Ja genau, also die, die es nicht kennen, webarchive.org, da könnt ihr von eurer Lieblingsseite mal gucken, wie die 1995 so aussah.
Da könnt ihr mal gucken, wie fritz.de 1999 aussah, wirklich sehr anders.
Ich weiß doch noch, dass Fritz einfach ganz stolz darauf war, dass jetzt auch CSS machen und die Seite sah auch total bunt aus. Da gab es auch am Anfang...
Da gab es Preise dafür, wir haben Preise abgesandt dafür ohne Ende.
Dass die Seite so schön bunt ist.
Ja die war nicht nur bunt, da gab es großen Button, da stand drauf musste klicken und wenn man den klicken musste, wenn man musste klicken, musste klicken, dann kam man weiter, die war der Knaller.
Ja aber ich glaube man kann schon so sagen, dass also mit dem Firefox dann auch so eine neue Ära wieder eingeleitet wurde, also am Anfang haben alle versucht, sich möglichst abzusetzen und möglichst tolle viele eigene Sachen zu machen und irgendwie gab es dann auch so eine Trendwende, dass dann gesagt hat okay, wir wollen jetzt möglichst wieder standardkonform zu sein. Zumindestens beim oder auch beim Internet Explorer ist ja wenigstens ein bisschen auch zu beobachten, dass sie da auch wieder in die Richtung gehen.
Ja am Anfang waren sie da aber ganz sportlich dabei, also sie haben auch CSS 2.0, also die zweite Version des Standards, eigentlich gleich mitimplementiert. Ja und was halt da anders war so vorher, wie gesagt im Web-Archiv könnt ihr gucken, wie die Seiten früher aussahen, das war dann ohne CSS und mit CSS war es auf einmal irgendwie, ich weiß auch nicht warum, aber wenn man mit CSS Webseiten gemacht hat, sahen die auf einmal schöner aus. Weil man sich vielleicht viel bewusster Gedanken darüber gemacht hat, wie man das jetzt gestalten möchte so, weil man irgendwie gesagt hat, ich parametrisiere jetzt meine Gestaltung in irgendwelchen Werten und irgendwie konnte man da viel schöner rumspielen, als jetzt im Editor mit What you see is, what you get irgendwie.
Der Wüsiwück, genau.
Ja irgendwie, man saß da damals im Editor und wollte dann ein Bild zentrieren oder sonst was und der Editor hat immer was anderes gemacht. Die Seite sah immer anders aus, als man sie eigentlich haben wollte. Und mit CSS hatte man dann wieder so mehr fein granulierte Kontrolle darüber, wie die Seite aussehen sollte. Und das haben echt auch viele zum Anlass genommen, so das Web erstmal wieder auf eine neue Stufe zu tragen. Nämlich erstens sahen die Seiten hübscher aus und zweitens war das halt mit diesen Standardkonformitäten irgendwie alles viel sauberer und aufgeräumter. Also es war irgendwie, das war ein großer Schritt, weil irgendwie sind auf einmal die Web-Designer aufgesprungen und haben irgendwie gesagt, ja, und jetzt geht's los.
Vor allem jetzt gibt's ja auch endlich mal was zu designen. Vorher war das ja alles, da konnte man halt irgendwie die Schrift grün machen und den Backen blau und so, aber so viel war da ja noch gar nicht. Wo kommt eigentlich das Cascading von Stylecheat her?
Naja, das ist im Prinzip, also XM oder XHTML oder HTML ist ja auch schon ineinander cascaded. Also es sind ja so Schachtelungen. Und dieses CSS macht im Prinzip, operiert ja auf diesen Verschachtelungen. Also du kannst halt nicht nur auf diesen verschachtelten Elementen deinen Style definieren, sondern du kannst halt auch, sagen wir mal, du machst eine Headline rot, ja, und in der Headline ist jetzt aber noch irgendwas anderes. Und dann kannst du sagen, ja, das da drin soll jetzt auch rot sein und es erbt so die Gestaltung von oben und von unten. Du kannst es ineinander stecken, also so ein bisschen verschachtelt.
Es sieht schicker aus.
Ja, du kannst einfach, du hast schon sehr große Möglichkeiten irgendwie mit bestimmten, ja wie soll man das sagen? Also im Prinzip funktioniert jetzt CSS so, man sagt irgendwie, das Element H4 soll jetzt grün sein. So und jetzt kann man eben nicht nur sagen, dass Element H4 ist, sondern man kann auch sagen, alle Elemente H4, die in einer Liste drin sind, die in einem Paragraph drin sind. Und dann verschachtelst du sozusagen deine Selektoren und Statements und kannst sie so ineinander mischen. Also es, ja, so würde ich jetzt dieses Cascading da drin erklären. Ist wahrscheinlich, wenn man auf Wikipedia nachguckt, noch irgendwie ein bisschen toller beschrieben, aber, ja.
Genau, und wenn ihr mal selber schauen wollt, bei eurer Lieblingswebseite, wie die aussieht, das sind in der Regel Dateien, die hinten auf.css enden für Cascading Style Sheets. Und diesen können aber auch im HTML-Qualitys in der Seite mit direkt eingebunden sein. Man kann auch diese Styles pro Element setzen. In der Regel ist es aber gerade bei komplexen Webseiten, ist es eben eine externe Datei, die dann von der Webseite mit eingebunden wird. Und, ja, dann zeigt die dahin. Die könnte aber auch einfach runterladen im Browser, die mir einfach die Datei-Namen oder sowas mit Copy-and-Paste in oben in die Adresszeile eingebt. Also nur mal so als Tipp, aber das wisst ihr wahrscheinlich eh schon.
So, und jetzt kann ich noch mal so ein bisschen von mir erzählen. Also ich war ja auch relativ früh online mit so Modem, Verlängerungskabel quer durchs Wohnzimmer gespannt und so weiter. Und im Internet-Sein war ja total der heiße Scheiß. Und natürlich habe ich auch My First Homepage gemacht, so auch mit so einem Visivic-Editor. Und danach, als das mit dem Browserkrieg losging und man sich nicht mehr darauf verlassen konnte, dass seine Seite in beiden Browsern gleich aussah, habe ich zum Beispiel ein bisschen Lust am Web verloren und habe dann eher so wieder klassische Print-Sachen gemacht. Bis dann halt in diese Cascading Style-Sheets kam mir irgendjemand mal gezeigt, guck mal, das muss jetzt alles gar nicht mehr so schlimm sein, das geht jetzt. Es gab auch so einen Punkt, wo Internet Explorer 6 und Firefox tatsächlich annähernd ähnliche Ergebnisse geliefert haben.
Wo man nicht mehr für jeden Browser eine separate Version basteln musste.
Genau, es gab so diese gefühlte Phase, wo das gleich war, sehr gleich stand. Und wie gesagt, wie ich gerade schon gemeint hab, da ging so das Web irgendwie so richtig nochmal ab. Dann haben irgendwie Leute, Gestalter, sich damit auseinandergesetzt und haben einfach verdammt hübsche und auch tolle Webseiten gemacht. Und das hat dafür gesorgt, dass irgendwie so große Firmen, vor allen Dingen große Firmen und sonst wer irgendwie gemeint haben, ja wir brauchen jetzt auch eine Webpräsenz, wir müssen da rein, das ist irgendwie total hip. Die Leute gehen da voll ab. Irgendwie, wir brauchen jetzt eine Webpräsenz. Und das war dann auch so die Zeit für New Economy 1.0. Irgendwie Pixel Park, vielleicht kennt ja der eine oder andere die Firma. Die haben dann so für eine Webpräsenz einfach Millionenbeträge aufgerufen. Ja, und das war halt so dieser erste große Schub im Web. Irgendwie jede Firma wollte da rein und wollte eine Webpräsenz und zeigen, wir sind modern, wir sind hip, wir können eine schöne Webseite machen und sie haben einfach Millionen verbrannt dafür. Das war für mich eigentlich Web 1.0. Alles davor war so, ja, für technisch Interessierte die Entwicklungsphase, möchte ich mal sagen.
Für die Nerd an sich und als solchen.
Ja, also genau. Also ich hatte nicht viele Freunde, die online waren. Also wenn ich irgendjemand erzählt habe, ich habe eine Homepage so 1996, so dann kann ich mir aber nicht angucken, ich habe kein Internet.
Ist schön, kommst du jetzt runter?
So war das dann schon. Und dann ist erstmal eine Zeit lang auch wieder nichts passiert. So dann war dieser Stand so. Und dann... Dann können wir so...
Flash kam denn irgendwann noch dazu, ne?
Oh ja, Flash werden war dabei ganz, ganz modern.
In unseren Aufzählungen vor der Sendung habe ich auch eine Sache vergessen, eine Web-Technologie, die schon ziemlich von Anfang an dabei war, die aber irgendwie keiner mehr auf dem Radar hat. Java. Kennt ihr euch erinnern, als Java rauskam, so Java Applets im Browser, das war doch das heißeste Seid geschnitten Brot, irgendwie die Idee, jetzt irgendwelche Java-Applikationen im Browser ausführen zu können. Also auf einer Webseite sogar, so irgendwie, was weiß ich, was gab es denn da, irgendwie irgendwelche simplen Demos gab es ja schon.
Also meistens haben die Leute nur irgendwelche dynamischen Menüs gemacht oder irgendwelche total sinnlosen Sachen auf der Webseite.
Du bist mit einer Maus über irgendein Menü und es wurde groß und klein und änderte die Farbe und so.
Ja, aber Java war tatsächlich recht früh dabei und das war irgendwie, als Java rauskam, war ja Ehenhype und dann irgendwie noch Applets in der Webseite. Krasses Zeug, aber heute benutzt es keine Sau.
Das war ja dennoch glaube ich einer der großen Killer für den Internet Explorer, weil die kein Java dabei hatten. Lizenzgründen damals noch.
Ich glaube, die mochten damals dann noch nicht so richtig. Also machen sie bis heute nicht. Flash. Genau, Flash war dann die nächste Sache und da fängt es jetzt so an, da geht es jetzt so in die Breite von Web-Technologien. Also wir hatten CSS für Aussehen machen und alles schick. Dann hatten wir JavaScript. Das gab es auch schon relativ früh. Zwar in unterschiedlichen Versionen in den jeweiligen Browsern, aber man konnte damit schon so Text blinken lassen und so Kleinigkeiten machen. So und dann kam noch dieses Flash hinzu. Und das war halt sozusagen wie so ein eigenes Programm im Browser nochmal drin. Weil das Flash hatte überhaupt nichts mit der HTML-Seite zu tun, außer dass es da drauf war. Aber um diesen Flash-Film abzuspielen oder anzuzeigen, war irgendwie komplett anderes Software eigentlich im Spiel. Nämlich dieses Flash-Plugin. So und da waren jetzt auf einmal wieder ganz andere Möglichkeiten gestimmt. Dann gab es nämlich die Phase, wo jeder seine Webseite in Flash gemacht hat.
Und die langsamen Internetverbindungen sind kollabiert, weil sie irgendwie bescheuerten Blinky-Blinky-Dinger laden mussten.
Genau, so und dann ging es halt los. So Flash, okay, dann können wir eine Grafik machen, die man so in HTML nicht machen konnte. Man konnte sie animieren. Ab einem bestimmten Punkt konnte man sie skripten. Also falls der eine oder andere das noch kennt, so Director von Macromedia war sozusagen der Vorläufer von Flash, könnte man sagen. Und da waren dann auf einmal ganz neue interaktive Konzepte möglich. Also das war auch so der Punkt, wo man dann tatsächlich so mit der Webseite so ein bisschen mehr noch interagieren konnte. Also irgendwie Buttons drücken ist das eine, aber so, ja, Animationen sehen, ausführen, auslösen, Sounds abspielen und solche Geschichten.
Ich glaube, das große Marketing-Argument war damals einfach, es sieht überall gleich aus, weil eben der Browser nicht mehr irgendwie das Entscheidende ist, sondern diese Software, die die Sachen anzeigt. Und auf der anderen Seite war es aber eben wieder so, dass Flash damals zumindest nur für Windows verfügbar war.
Mac auch.
Mac dann auch irgendwann, genau. Und aber natürlich die ganzen Unix-Systeme sind dann außen voll geblieben.
Genau, also das ist auch übrigens durchaus eine wichtige Entwicklung, dass so der Unix-Baum der Computerwelt einfach so einen Teil vom Internet gar nicht sehen konnte. So Flash-Plugins für Unix-Browser gab es einfach nicht. Gibt es bis heute nicht richtig. Also wenn auf dem Linux heutzutage Ubuntu irgendwie eine Seite mit Flash zum Beispiel, adobe.com ist ein gutes Beispiel, da liegt der Flash-Film immer über der Seite selber. Also du kannst nicht aufs Menü klicken, das HTML-Menü, weil das Flash einfach immer drüber liegt.
Du hast ein schönes Bild benutzt, du hast gesagt, die Hälfte der User kann ein Stückchen vom Internet gar nicht sehen. Die wissen gar nicht, dass es das gibt. Ein schönes Bild auf jeden Fall.
Die sind auf jeden Fall da, außen vor.
Wenn wir uns heute in einer Welt bewegen, ich will jetzt nicht zu weit vorgreifen, aber wo der Browser mehrere Unterschiede, also nicht nur eine Website anzeigen kann und Sachen animieren kann oder so, sondern mir gleichzeitig auch noch einen Wetterbericht gibt, automatisch also kleine Widgets mit einbauen kann und so. Wo geht denn das noch hin? Was wird denn der Browser irgendwann alles können? Gibt es da schon so einen Ausblick?
Vielleicht noch ein ganz kurzer Einwurf.
Was ist dir den Gedanken für nachher noch irgendwie aufgehört?
Es gab nämlich noch eine ganz bizare Technologie, die nennt sich Active Desktop. Ja, Active Desktop, genau, da erstmals eingeführt mit Windows 98. Wo man die Idee hatte, hey, HTML ist ja total toll. Und wir bauen jetzt mal diesen ganzen Desktop in HTML. Das heißt, meine ganzen Explorer-Fans, alles war dann irgendwie eine Webseite. Das war die Idee. Die ist man aber ziemlich schnell wieder von abgekommen, weil es irgendwie alles überhaupt nicht performt hat und langsam war. Und es war irgendwie mal so eine komische Unsitte, die damals irgendwie war. Und ich hab festgestellt gerade, dass teilweise immer noch Windows 2000 und Installationen, die es ja immer nochmal gibt, auch diesen Active Desktop irgendwie aktiviert haben. Den muss man dann ganz schnell erstmal deaktivieren, sonst ist das ganze System praktisch unbrauchbar, weil es irgendwie auch wahnsinnig Speicher frisst und letztendlich war es auch irgendwie eine riesige Sicherheitslücke, mehr oder weniger.
Ja, also war bei F95 tatsächlich schon als Feature verfügbar. Ja, okay, also Flash.
Wir können kurz eine Überlege-Musik spielen.
Lass uns doch mal eine Überlege-Musik spielen, also es gibt ja jetzt verschiedene Pfade, die wir beschreiten können. Hyperlinks folgen.
Welchen Weg werden die drei lustigen Herren von Chaosradio gehen? Bleiben sie dran. Chaosradio auf Fritz 0331 70 97 110. Everlast, Delon und Dalkon, Chaos Radio auf Fritz. Gab es gerade eine Anfrage, wie ist es eigentlich mit Leuten, die in der Schule jetzt immer noch Java lernen und sich damit beschäftigen? Ihr habt doch gerade gesagt, Java ist eigentlich total Web 1.0 und es braucht keiner mehr. Huckel, kannst du das mal gerade rücken?
Naja, also man benutzt halt Java nicht mehr, um Java Applets auf eine Seite zu tun, aber Java benutzt man sehr wohl, um sozusagen das, was auf einem Web-Server passiert, um so eine Webseite zu generieren. Da wird das sehr stark und viel und oft benutzt. Also große Anwendungen, Web-Anwendungen, die wirklich komplexe Sachverhalte abbilden und für große Firmen sind, die basieren hinter der Tür sozusagen auf Java und wirklich sehr weit verbreitet und das ist auch keine stehende Entwicklung. Das geht immer weiter und das kann überhaupt nicht schaden, sich da mit Java auszukennen, weil es gibt, genauso wie es für Frontend-Entwickler gibt, also für HTML und CSS und JavaScript, gibt es genauso einen großen Markt für Leute, die mit Java Web-Anwendungen entwickeln können.
Also wenn ihr gerade im Informatikkurs oder wo auch immer in der Schule Java lernt und gehofft habt, ihr könnt ab morgen sagen, wir kommen nicht mehr, weil es brauchen wir nicht mehr. Nichts ist, ihr müsst leider länger bleiben, aber ihr könnt es dann irgendwann auf jeden Fall noch benutzen.
Genau und wo wir gerade noch bei den Fragen sind, ich habe ja auch noch zwei Fragen per Mail bekommen, wo ich noch mal ganz kurz was zu sagen will. Das eine ist eine Frage nach den Randgruppen-Browsern, also diesen kleineren Sachen, kleinere Projekte, irgendwelche Ableger von den großen Browsern, ob wir da was zu sagen können, oder eben ganz neue. Ich glaube, es ist ein bisschen schwierig. Also ich weiß nicht, ich habe so großartige Projekte von Rendering-Engines, also die Teile des Browsers sind die, die Darstellungen machen, außer jetzt den üblichen verdächtigen Webkit.
Naja, also es gibt die meisten kleineren Projekte, neben einfach die Open Source Engines von Firefox oder von Safari oder von Opera, falls die jetzt mittlerweile Open Source ist, und machen einfach nur eine eigene Oberfläche darüber und sparen vielleicht ein paar Features. Also ich würde da sagen, geht einfach auf die Wikipedia-Liste aller Web-Browser. Ich hatte die schon offen, die ist wirklich ellenlang, und da gibt es auch einen, also Vergleichs, Grafiken, lest euch das durch. Also ich persönlich benutze zum Beispiel Safari und Firefox in regelmäßigen Wechsel, und das reicht. Ich brauche jetzt nicht drei Gazillionen Browser, und die tun ihren Job gut genug für mich.
Aber im Endeffekt muss jeder selber entscheiden für die Anwendung, die ihr braucht, was ihr da habt, ausprobieren und dann sagen ja oder nie.
Genau, die andere Sache war noch eine Frage, das ist eigentlich fast ein bisschen was für später, aber ich mache es trotzdem, ich mache mal, wo wir schon dabei sind. Der Daniel hat nachgefragt, es gibt so Plug-Ins für den Browser, womit man zum Beispiel direkt von YouTube oder anderen Video-Webseiten direkt sozusagen die Videos runterrippen kann, also direkt von da runterladen kann. Und das wäre irgendwie in den AGBs nicht so vorgesehen, ob man sich da irgendwie strafbar macht. Das ist aber strafbar sowieso nicht im strafrechtlichen Sinne nach dem deutschen Recht, sondern es ist dann höchstens ein Verstoß gegen die AGBs. Aber wenn ihr die irgendwie gar nicht ordentlich akzeptiert habt oder so bestätigt habt mit dem Klick oder so, dann ist es eigentlich auch problemlos. Also das könnt ihr auf jeden Fall sorgenfrei benutzen.
Der letzte Stichpunkt in Sachen Technologie, wir haben ja über CSS und Java und Flash und so gesprochen, war auch Web 1.0, was ganz schön war, da kommt ein Garantiert jetzt Web 2.0.
Genau, das reißen wir eigentlich auch mal ganz kurz ab, weil das würde die Sendung problemlos noch füllen und das kann man...
Also Web 2.0, ganz kurz zusammengefasst, nicht nur der User kommuniziert, gibt Sachen in seinen Rechner ein, sondern es gibt eine Interaktion. Und MySpace verdient viel Geld und alle wollen das machen.
Naja, also der Gedanke bei Web 2.0 ist, also viele verbinden das mit technologischen Entwicklungen, nämlich diesem AJAX, diesen asynchronen Java-Skript, das können wir auch kurz nochmal ansprechen, aber eigentlich ist der Gedanke weg von einfach nur Webseiten, wo man irgendwie Informationen liest hin zu kollaborativen Webseiten, also Online-Communities, irgendwie wir sharen Sachen, wir tun unser Wissen ins Netz und wir machen das möglichst so gut, dass irgendwie das erstens maschinenlesbar ist, also dass es sozusagen auch in andere Webseiten ein Problem muss integriert werden kann, dass Programme das runterziehen können, verstehen können, damit die Suchmaschinen das parsen können und so weiter. Also das ist eher so das Web so semantisch zusammenweben. Ja, also irgendwie, wenn sich Google eine Seite anguckt, weiß es halt, okay, hier ist eine Überschrift, da ist ein Paragraph und so weiter. Das ist ja eh schon bekannt, aber das ist eben noch verknüpft mit, wir tun jetzt all unser Wissen rein, damit es auch irgendwas zum Suchen überhaupt gibt. Also Wikipedia ist erstens das beste Beispiel für Hypertext, also dieses klassische, wir verlinken Seiten und zum anderen eben gemeinsames Wissen einfach ins Netz zu tun.
Und auch ein gutes Beispiel dafür, dass man nicht alles glauben sollte, was im Internet steht, weil nur wenn 5000 Leute sagen, Weihnachten ist am 28. August, heißt das noch lange nicht, dass das wirklich stimmt.
Dafür gibt es ja Google Fight.
Wobei das mit dem semantischen Web, das geht ja eigentlich noch ein bisschen weiter. Also die Idee ist, dass man den Informationen jeweils eben noch diesen semantischen Kontext gibt und da sind wir glaube ich aber noch ein ganzes Stück weit von entfernt. Also dieses Querverlinken ist das eine, was bei Wikipedia passiert. Aber dieses eigentlich wirkliche, im wirklichen Sinne semantische Web, das ist glaube ich noch Zukunftsmusik. Und die Frage ist auch, ob da wirklich so ein echtes Interesse dran besteht, das zu machen, weil es einfach ein riesiger Aufwand wäre.
Aber diese Verstrickung findet schon krass statt. Also wenn du in deinem Blog was schreibst, das ist erstens eine Minute später schon bei Google. Also habe ich gestern erst wieder gehabt, Blogpost geschrieben, danach gegoogelt, war peng, sofort drin. Genauso irgendwie bei anderen Suchmaschinen. Also dieses, ich stelle eine Information ins Netz und die Information, als ich gerade was reingeschrieben habe, verteilt sich auf verschiedenste Orte und wird einfach irgendwo announced. Und irgendwelche Leute gucken halt drauf und irgendwo hast du Minuten später einen Kommentar im Blog. Das war einfach vorher nicht so. Also dieses vernetzte...
Wobei da sicherlich auch zu bedenken ist, dass die Internetzugänge wesentlich einfacher geworden sind und schneller geworden sind. Und es ist einfacher, an den unterschiedlichsten Orten online zu gehen. Du musst nicht mehr irgendwie nach Hause mit deinem Bruder einschalten und so, sondern du bist einfach online. Und dadurch kriegen es natürlich viele Leute viel schneller mit. Dadurch kommen die Comments schneller.
Aber es ist halt trotzdem irgendwie... Es wird halt überall aggregiert und bekannt gemacht. RSS und den ganzen Kram. Also wie gesagt, auch da ein Verweis einfach auf die Wikipedia Web 2.0. Da steht schon dieser semantische oder dieser dieser gemeinschaftliche Gedanke im Vordergrund. Und der wird auch durchaus getragen durch dieses AIACS. Das heißt, man klickt auf einen Link und kommt nicht zu einer anderen Seite, sondern im Hintergrund. Die Seite bleibt einfach auf dem Browser. Lädt der Browser so von irgendeinem Server neue Informationen und lädt die einfach in die bestehende Seite gerade mit rein.
Dynamisches HTML. Ist da auch eine...
Dynamisches HTML. Das heißt, früher wurde die Seite reingeladen und da war sie. Da ist nichts weiter mit passiert. Und jetzt lädst du eine Webseite und dann klickst du auf einen Link und auf einmal baut sich die Webseite um. Neue Elemente erscheinen, die Farbe ändert sich, was auch immer.
Genau, das ist eigentlich eine Errungenschaft, der von JavaScript, wo ich also entsprechend einen kleinen Programmcode in die Webseite einbauen kann, dass wenn dies und jenes passiert, dann soll sich die Seite in sich selbst verändern, also die Inhalte.
AJAX kommt auch von Microsoft, ne? Das ist auch tatsächlich... ActiveX irgendwie, dieses AJAX wurde von Microsoft erlacht und das haben dann... das war kein Web-Standard, das haben dann einfach die anderen Browser selber noch mitimplementiert und irgendwann wurde es dann Web-Standard.
Es gibt ja noch zwei große Stichworte, um die wir in dieser Sendung gerne noch rumsegeln würden. Das eine sind selbstverständlich die Sicherheitslücken, die immer wieder auftauchen, wenn es um die Frage geht, welchen Browser benutzt man jetzt und wenn alle Leute sagen, Internet Explorer ist böse, böse, böse, böse, böse. Und zum anderen geht es um Browser, Web-Browser basierte Anwendungen, die man also da mit dem Browser benutzen kann. Was wird in Zukunft mit dem Browser passieren? Was wird da alles möglich sein? Schaffen wir das jetzt noch in den gut drei Minuten vor Nachrichten oder wollen wir es nach Nachrichten machen?
Also zumindestens zu den Sicherheitslücken können wir mit einem Mythos aufräumen, nämlich dass Open Source Software generell sicher ist oder sicherer ist. Das ist glaube ich mal ein ganz ganz großer Mythos, weil diese Dinge einfach mittlerweile so komplex geworden sind, dass freiwillige Entwicklerteams, selbstwahrscheinlich bezahlte Entwicklerteams, nicht mal eben so die ganzen Sicherheitsprobleme überblicken können. Da entsteht einfach viel Kot und es ist völlig normal und auch jetzt nicht übermäßig verwerflich, dass es auch mal Sicherheitslücken gibt. Das Entscheidende ist, wie wird mit den Sicherheitslücken umgegangen und wie viele Leute gucken darauf. Und da ist es jetzt so eine Philosophiesache, ob man sagt, okay es ist eine macht eine Software sicherer, wenn da keiner außer dem Hersteller drauf guckt oder macht es eine Software sicherer, wenn da ganz viele Leute drauf gucken. Aber es eben nur dann bringt auch wirklich noch was, wenn wenn da Leute wirklich qualifiziert drauf gucken und dann auch entsprechende Sicherheitslücken melden.
Wie ist da deine persönliche Meinung dazu?
Naja, also ich finde es schon sympathisch, wenn man offen und ehrlich mit den Sachen umgeht, wenn dann einmal im Monat so ein großes Patchpaket kommt, sagt wir haben jetzt ein paar Sicherheitslücken beseitigt. Dann kann einerseits schön sein, andererseits beruhigend, andererseits finde ich es persönlich aber angenehmer, wenn ich weiß, ok, da ist ein Sicherheitsproblem. Ich kann, ich traue mir das zu zu beurteilen, ob das jetzt wirklich mich persönlich betrifft, wie ich mich möglicherweise verhalten kann, was ich tun kann, um den Browser sicher zu benutzen, bis das nächste Update da ist, bis die Sicherheitslücke behoben ist. Das ist aber wirklich so eine Sache, wie man seinen Computer benutzt und seine Software benutzt. Ob man sagt, das ist mir egal, macht das irgendwie ganz, oder ich habe jetzt den Anspruch, auch zu verstehen, was da so ungefähr passiert.
Also von der Geschwindigkeit, wie da Sicherheitslücken behoben werden, nehmen sie sich eigentlich auch nicht so richtig viel. Also auch Microsoft patcht schon relativ zeitnah die Sicherheitslücken. Also man kennt das ja vielleicht als Windows-Benutzer, dass da alle drei Tage irgendwie ein Internet Explorer-Sicherheitsupdate kommt. Und die Open Source Leute, die sind natürlich auch schnell dabei. Also da hat man jetzt nicht so einen Vorteil zwischen Open Source oder proprietären Software. Das ist einfach wirklich, ja, also bei Open Source hat man so als Computer-affiner Mensch eigentlich immer so ein besseres Gefühl. Die Jungs kämpfen da, wenn man gerade so ein bisschen die Web-Technologien kennt und weiß, was die da für Schmerzen auf sich nehmen, um die Welt ein bisschen besser zu machen mit einem tollen Browser, dann unterstützt man das schon eher. Die sind halt auch bei den Web-Standards in der Regel ein bisschen fleißiger dabei.
Also generell zu Sicherheitsproblemen beim Browser, ich glaube das größte Einfallstor ist wahrscheinlich ja das Skript und auch irgendwelche Plugins.
Ja, der User ist erstmal das größte Einfallstor. Weil der Browser kann noch so tolle Sicherheitsmaßnahmen haben, wenn du auf den falschen Link klickst, dann klickst du auf den falschen Link, dann kann der Browser nix machen.
Dann gibt es natürlich noch ganz unglückliche Kombinationen von Internet Explorer und Safari. Was war das für eine Geschichte, dass das Downloads automatisch auf dem Desktop abgelegt werden und die Internet Explorer auch noch gleich geöffnet werden? Nein, die geöffnet nicht, sondern der Internet Explorer lädt Dateien vom Desktop, wenn sie entsprechend angewiesen werden. Das war so eine ganz gruselige Kombination. Da ist es jetzt egal, ob das eine kommerzielle oder freie Software ist. Bei so einer unglücklichen Kombination kann einem das einfach dermaßen auf die Füße fallen. Damit muss ich als Anwender auch rechnen. Das heißt, wenn ich mit dem Computer das Internet benutze, egal ob ich da jetzt Web-Browser oder E-Mail oder was auch immer mache, ich muss einfach verdammt aufpassen, sobald das Internet im Spiel ist.
Aber das ist eine andere Geschichte.
Das ist eine andere Geschichte, genau. Nach den Nachrichten wollen wir darüber sprechen über Anwendungen, die nicht mehr auf unserem PC installiert werden, sondern die dann im Browser laufen. Da gibt es so ganz tolle Sachen. Google hat irgendwie so eine ganze Office-Suite. Es gibt irgendwie Grafikprogramme, also Fotobearbeitung, Grafikprogramme. Was gibt es noch so Klassiker?
Alles möglich. Also ich könnte noch eine...
Das ist im weitesten Sinne die Variante, dass du von jedem Rechner der Welt arbeiten könntest, wenn du ein Passwort hast und dich auf eine Webseite einloggst und nicht mehr die Programme auf deiner Festplatte mit dir rumträgst.
Genau, da wollen wir mit euch auch darüber sprechen, ob ihr glaubt, dass das die Zukunft ist. Ob das der richtige Weg ist oder ob das alles Murks ist. Wie ist eure Erfahrung mit der Bedienung von solchen Sachen? Benutzt ihr so eine Software, findet ihr total toll? Was ist eure Empfehlung, was nicht? Und wie seht ihr, das ist der Weg der Zukunft? Oder glaubt ihr, dass es jetzt nur so ein kurzer Hype ist?
0331 70 97 110 Wenn diese Jungs ein ganz, ganz besonderes Konzert in Berlin geben, sind wir natürlich dabei.
Fritz präsentiert NERD, die MySpace Secret Show. NERD, NERD kommen am Freitag ab 21 Uhr im Roten Salon der Volksbühne Berlin, die MySpace Secret Show.
Und was ist daran jetzt noch secret?
Na jetzt eigentlich nicht mehr. Aber es heißt nun mal so. Fritz, Info, Nachrichten.
Finale. Oh, mit Matthias Sachow.
Deutschland steht im Finale der Fußball-Europameisterschaft. Das DFB-Team besiegte in Basel die Türkei mit 3 zu 2. Die Tore für Deutschland schossen Schweinsteiger und Klose. Und in der 90. Minute war es Philipp Lahm, der den Siegtreffer erzielte. Nach dem Spiel blieb es bislang ruhig in Berlin und Brandenburg. An Deutschlands größter Fan-Meile rund ums Brandenburger Tor in Berlin feierten 500.000 Fans friedlich. Weil der Kurfürstendamm mit einem Autokorso gerade vollständig überfüllt ist, hat die Polizei die Straße abgesperrt. Auch hier feiern türkische und deutsche Fans gemeinsam. Morgen Abend entscheidet sich im zweiten EM-Halbfinale, ob die Deutschen am Sonntag in Wien gegen Spanien oder Russland um den Titel spielen. Der Streit um die Wiederholung der Mathe-Prüfung für den mittleren Schulabschluss an Berliner Schulen geht weiter. Bildungssenator Zöllner legte inzwischen ein Gutachten eines Wissenschaftlers der Humboldt-Universität vor, wonach die Aufgaben nicht schwerer waren als bei der ersten Klausur. Der Vorsitzende des Landeselternausschusses Schindler widersprach dem Gutachten und berief sich auf andere Experten. Unabhängig vom Streit hat Zöllner die Kriterien für das Bestehen der Klausur herabgesetzt. Jetzt bestehen die Schüler die Klausur schon mit 45 statt mit 50 Prozent der Punkten. Die Bundesregierung will mehr gegen die wachsende Zahl übergewichtiger Menschen in Deutschland tun. Jetzt soll es einen bundesweiten Aktionsplan für gesunde Ernährung und mehr Bewegung geben. Mit Kampagnen in öffentlichen Einrichtungen sollen ernährungsbedingte Krankheiten vermieden werden. Auch die Lebensmittelindustrie soll ihren Beitrag leisten und freiwillig auf Süßwarenwerbung verzichten, die sich an Kinder unter 12 Jahren richtet. Die Verbraucherschutzorganisation Foodwatch kritisierte, die Pläne seien nicht ausreichend. Statt freiwilliger Vereinbarungen mit der Industrie müsse die Regierung verbindliche Regeln vorschreiben. Die Strafrechtsverschärfung für Neonazi-Kundgebungen ist verfassungsgemäß. Das hat das Bundesverwaltungsgericht in einem Grundsatzurteil entschieden. Damit bestätigten die Richter das Verbot einer Kundgebung zum Todestag des Hitler-Stellvertreters Hess im bayerischen Bunnsiedel. Das dortige Landratsamt hatte 2005 eine geplante Veranstaltung verboten und sich dabei auf den verschärften Verfolgsverhetzungsparagrafen bezogen. Danach macht sich strafbar, wer öffentlich die Würde der NS-Opfer verletzt oder nationalsozialistische Gewalt- und Willkürherrschaft belässt. Machen wir erst das Wetter. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen Neurupin 16 Grad, Cottbus, Wittenberge und Angermünde 18, Potsdam und Frankfurt 19 Grad und in Berlin 20 Grad momentan. In Richtung Lausitz gibt es heute Nacht noch gewittrigen Regen, der zieht später nach Osten ab. Die Temperaturen liegen nachts zwischen 12 und 16 Grad. Morgen ist es meist heiter. Später kommen von Westen her wieder mehr Wolken dazu. Es bleibt aber meist trocken bei maximal 26 Grad. Aber natürlich Stadtverkehr Berlin in der Innenstadt. Gibt es viele Behinderungen wegen des EM-Spiels Deutschland-Türkei. Wegen der Fan-Meile ist die Straße des 17. Juni zwischen Brandenburger Tor und Großem Stern gesperrt. Außerdem geht auf dem Kuhdamm nichts mehr. Am besten das Auto stehen lassen und mit öffentlichen Fahren. Ansonsten, euch überall eine gute Fahrt. Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 1, dann Fritz in der Prignitz.
Wir sind im Chaos Radio Teil 136. Hockniss hier, Frank ist hier, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Wir freuen uns über eure Anrufe, falls ihr nicht irgendwo im Stau steht auf dem Kuhl am unter 0331 70 97 110. Wir reden nämlich über Browser. Wir hatten schon die Entwicklung vom Nichts zum Browser. Was macht der Browser mit dem Server, damit eine Website draus wird? Welche Technologien gibt es da? Und Frank ist eben ganz kurz auf die Sicherheitslücken eingegangen. Und natürlich müssen wir uns auf das kaprizieren, was mit dem Browser in Zukunft so möglich sein wird. Mit web-basierten Browser-Anwendungen. Richtig, das war das Stichwort, wo wir stehen geblieben sind.
Ich wollte noch eine kurze Geschichte zu diesen Sicherheitsgeschichten lesen. Also erzählen, nicht lesen. Und zwar mit diesen Communities, die wir auch kurz angesprochen hatten. Dann ging es ja dann auch so los, so bei Myspace oder anderen, könnte man dann seine eigene Profilseite machen. Das heißt, es war jetzt schon der Punkt, wo es zu kompliziert war, selber im Visivic-Editor eine Seite zusammen zu draggen. Und es war einfach viel einfacher, zu Myspace zu gehen und sagen hier, das bin ich, ich bin im Internet und das höre ich für Musik und das sind meine Freunde. So und dann haben die natürlich erlaubt, dass man seine Profilseite auch gestalterisch modifizieren kann. Und man konnte auch JavaScript einbinden. Und was dann so passiert ist, ist, dass findige Hacker mit diesem JavaScript auf der Seite, die Profildaten von anderen geklaut haben, also die Zugänge und die Profilseiten von anderen übernommen haben, mehr oder weniger. Natürlich hat sich dann MySpells gedacht, klar, dann verbieten wir jetzt JavaScript. Und dann ist aber folgendes passiert, es gibt im Internet Explorer, also im 6er war das glaube ich, gab es die Möglichkeit in einem Style Sheet JavaScript zu inkludieren über so eine HTC-Files, keine Ahnung. Und die haben einfach den gleichen Hack nochmal für alle Internet Explorer User gemacht, in dem sie einfach das Style Sheet genommen haben, um da das JavaScript zu inkludieren. Und das ist auch nochmal so diese Brücke zum Anfang und so, mitten drin. Du hast halt so viele Technologien und keiner kennt alle und es kann dann einfach passieren, du machst JavaScript aus und denkst dir, haha, jetzt ist alles sicher und dann findet jemand raus, dass Internet Explorer in seiner CSS-Implementation erlaubt nochmal JavaScript nachzuladen und du hast das gleiche Problem wieder. Ja, das nur so als Anekdote am Rande, also das ist Sicherheit im Netz, gibt es einfach nicht.
Vielleicht nochmal ein ganz kurzer Hinweis, weil es auch, also es ist hier auf der Mitmachseite vom Chaosradio erwähnt, unter wiki.chaosradio.ccc.de, dass Barrierefreiheit natürlich auch ein ganz ganz wichtiges Stichwort geworden ist, wo also mehr Behörden und wichtige Institutionen mittlerweile auch Internetauftritte haben und auch Dienste per Internet anbieten und da sind natürlich diese Style-Sheets auch ziemlich wertvoll, weil man einfach eine sehr einfache Basisversion der Webseite machen kann, die dann zum Beispiel auch mit so Braille-Lesegeräten ist, wo man dann die Schrift attasten kann oder man kann einfach auf bestimmte kontrastreiche Darstellungen umschalten und sowas geht natürlich besonders gut mit CSS. Insofern ist es also auch aus dem Aspekt schon mal eine wichtige Neuerung gewesen.
Ja, aber das ist genau dann auch semantisches Web. Wir räumen jetzt mal unseren HTML-Code auf, machen den mal bedeutungsvoller. Wir machen jetzt nicht irgendwie eine Table und da irgendwie einen Text rein und lassen ihn so aussehen wie eine Überschrift, aber in Wirklichkeit ist es gar keine, sondern wir benutzen so die HTML-Elemente, wie sie gedacht waren und damit dann eben auch auf einem Braille-Gerät das verwertet werden kann.
Okay, dann lass uns mal zu den Anwendungen kommen, weil wenn ich auf die Uhr gucke, wir haben noch eine Schalte zum Cooldump, wo ja gerade nichts geht. Wir haben also, sagen wir mal, über einen Daumen noch eine Viertelstunde.
Ja, also ich benutze keine Web-Anwendungen. Also es gibt ja da so, also ein ganz großer Anbieter von diesen Web-Anwendungen ist natürlich Google. Die haben irgendwie relativ früh angefangen, weiß nicht, war Gmail das erste, womit es so groß rausgegangen ist?
Also man muss ja bei Web-Anwendungen, gibt es eigentlich so eine Definition? Also ich meine, ist jetzt einfach mein GMX-Webmail-Dings oder generell irgendwie ein Web-Mail-Dings, ist es schon eine Web-Applikation oder fängt eine Web-Applikation erst dann an, wenn sie auch, sage ich mal, ohne Rückweg bei mir im Browser funktioniert, also ohne sozusagen, wenn ich quasi den Modem auflegen könnte, die Verbindung trennen könnte und erst wenn es darum geht, quasi irgendwas weiterzumachen, Text zu speichern oder so?
Naja, ich würde die Grenze so ziehen. Also im Prinzip ist es schon so, dass so ein Web-Mail so klassischer Art irgendwie auch eine Art Web-Applikation ist, aber es fängt irgendwie schon in dem Moment an, wo du so eigene Benutzer-Interfaces hast, die das erlauben, was normalerweise nur über Browser-Menüs oder über dein Betriebssystem möglich sind, also so Copy-and-Paste nochmal selber in der Web-Applikation drin, weißt du, wenn so eine Sache anfangen, dass du in der Webseite irgendwie bestimmte Tools zur Verfügung hast, mit denen du klicken, draggen und droppen und Kampen pasten kannst.
Dass man bei Google Text zum Beispiel einen Text schreiben kann, als ob man einen Text schreiben würde, aber du schreibst den nicht auf deinem Rechner, sondern auf einer Webseite.
Also da fängt für mich dann so richtig Web-Applikation eigentlich an. Auf der Wikiseite stand ja, es wäre gut, auf iOS einzugehen, das ist halt irgendwie, die implementieren auf einer Webseite sozusagen nochmal dein Betriebssystem Desktop nach. Also du hast dann irgendwie auch einen Home-Folder und einen Trash. Es ist irgendwie total unbenutzbar und du hast halt irgendwie kaum sinnvolle Programme da drauf, aber es ist irgendwie, ja, du hast dann einfach deinen Desktop nochmal im Browser.
Ist das auch so eine Geschichte, die jetzt noch in den Kinderschuhen steckt und wo alle versuchen, möglichst mitzumischen und später nicht hinten dran zu stehen?
Also ich werte das eher so als ausloten, was geht. Also gerade so diese Open Source, wir machen jetzt den Desktop im Webprojekt, ist eigentlich so, was geht alles im Web? Was kann ich mit den Technologien, die es jetzt wirklich im Browser gibt, alles machen? Und man stellt fest, verdammt viel.
Also es gibt ja die sogenannten thin-kleins, also schmale, dünne, klein, kleine PCs, Arbeitsplatz-PCs, dieses Konzept gibt es schon relativ lange und bisher liefen da denn irgendwelche entweder in der Unix-Welt, im Prinzip einfach nur irgendwelche Darstellungen für X-Windows-System, wo also die Applikation selbst auf einem entfernten Server lief, aber mein Gerät, quasi was ich unterm Schreibtisch hatte oder so, oder auf dem Schreibtisch zu stehen hatte, hat dann nur die Anzeige übernommen. Es hat also über das Netzwerk kommuniziert und da wurde quasi die Display-Anzeige, die Bildschirmanzeige wurde dann per Netz auf mein Gerät verlagert und die Eingabe entsprechend zurück übertragen. So ein bisschen ähnliches Konzept ist vielleicht bei diesen browserbasierten Anwendungen auch zu sehen. Das heißt, die Idee, ich habe einfach einen Client, wo ich keine Software installieren muss, wo ich nichts pflegen muss, sondern das Einzige, was da ist, da geht irgendwie das Ding fährt hoch und dann geht ein Browser auf und dann bin ich da.
Das ist halt auch zum Beispiel, also Flash ist ja die weitverbreitetste Web-Technologie überhaupt. Also es ist noch mehr deployed als Browser mit Javascript, mit eingeschalteten, also es gibt mehr Leute die, ja, also ich, kennst du jemanden ohne Flash, also die, abgesehen von den Linux-Usern. Ne, und deswegen ist das halt zum Beispiel auch so eine beliebte Plattform, eigentlich um Web-Applikationen zu bauen, aber...
Naja, bei Flash hast du halt wieder das Problem, es ist dann ein proprietäres System und es ist dann schon wieder vielleicht ein bisschen evil, sondern man will natürlich ein möglichst offen sein und vielleicht auch bei der Entwicklung her freies Software verwenden oder zumindest nicht auf einen Hersteller angewiesen sein.
Karma-Punkte sammeln.
Genau.
Ja, ok, jetzt können wir halt, wie gesagt, mal so, ja, ich weiß nicht, also wie gesagt, ich benutze das nicht so, ich benutze kein Google-Mail und ich benutze auch, ich editiere meine Fotos im Photoshop und ich stehe eher so auf Desktop-Applikationen. Es gab noch keine Web-Applikation, nämlich so richtig vom Hocker.
Jetzt müsste du eine Web-Applikation haben, die dich so wegbläst. Worauf wartest du denn?
Naja, eigentlich, äh, der Browser im Browser, haha.
Nee, also ich meine, es gibt jetzt, es gibt jetzt von Microsoft zum Beispiel ein neues Plugin, das heißt Silverlight, ja, da kannst du irgendwie mit Ruby, mit Python, mit irgendwie.NET Sprachen, also diesen, was weiß ich, was da alles dazugehört, Java bestimmt auch, oder? C-Sharp. Kannst halt irgendwie alle möglichen Programmiersprachen benutzen, um in deinem Browser in so einem extra Fenster oder in so einer Virtual Machine in dem Browser irgendwie Applikationen zu bauen. Das ist schon interessant, weil du da irgendwie mächtige Mittel in der Hand hast, um wirklich sinnvolle Applikationen zu bauen. Mail-Client habe ich auf der Platte, der funktioniert auch ziemlich gut. Also ich bin auch nicht so ein Typ, der ohne Notebook jetzt irgendwie im Internet-Café sitzt und Mail liest. Für so eine Leute ist das natürlich total toll. Oder jetzt Fotos bearbeiten, also irgendwie die Performance ist einfach schlecht, das ist langsam. Also Browser ist einfach eines der langsamsten Environments, um irgendwie überhaupt Sachen zu machen und da jetzt auch noch Bilder drin zu bearbeiten.
Ja, weil es im Endeffekt natürlich immer noch daran liegt, wie dick ist die Datenleitung, die da hinten reingeht.
Ja, nicht nur, also der Browser ist einfach sowieso langsam. Also jeder kleine Pixel, der sich ändert, verursacht, dass die ganze Seite neu gerendert wird. Und wie wir ja anfangs schon erklärt haben, ist das ziemlich teuer in der Rechenzeit. Und dadurch, also wenn du einen Pixel an und aus machst mit 25 Frames die Sekunde, dann ist deine CPU dicht. So ist 100% CPU-Last nur wegen einem Pixel. Und ja, das sagt eigentlich schon ziemlich viel über die Performance von Browsern. Und ja, für mich ist das nichts.
Also ich denke schon, dass es ein paar Anwendungen gibt, aber das sind dann mehr Anwendungen, die dann wirklich auch serverbasiert sind. Also klassischen Datenbank-Abfragen und so Geschichten, da macht es wahrscheinlich Sinn, die browserbasiert zu haben. Aber ich glaube so, also ein wirklicher Satz, also ich persönlich bin da skeptisch. Also mich würde auch interessieren, ob es einfach Leute gibt, die das nutzen. Und also ich persönlich kann mir das jetzt nicht so vorstellen, dass das irgendwie die Technologie der Zukunft ist. Andererseits, vielleicht ist es auch eine Sache oder eine Tendenz, die wir auch ein bisschen dem Erfolg von Linux und dem Erfolg von Mac OS auch zu verdanken haben, dass nämlich einfach Windows nicht mehr die Softwareplattform ist. So, vorher war es ganz klar, Firma entwickelt Software für Windows. Punkt. So, keine Diskussion. So, und jetzt kommen aber mittlerweile halt doch mal so ein paar Mac-User und ein paar Linux-User. Hey, wie sieht es mit uns aus? Oder sagen die Unis, die sagen, ne, wir machen nur freie Software Linux oder Unix-basierten Sachen bei den Grafikern natürlich oder den ganzen Kreativen, wieder Mac sehr beliebt. Und sagen, wir hätten aber auch gerne irgendwie ein Office-Paket. Und so, und das da vielleicht so, vielleicht auch ein bisschen mehr der Bedarf überhaupt da ist, wieder eine einheitliche Plattform zu haben. Und diese einheitliche Plattform, meint man, wäre jetzt ein Browser, oder?
Also im Endeffekt kann man sagen, da ist noch eine ganze Menge offen, da passiert noch eine ganze Menge in der Situation. Ich wollte noch ganz kurz anfügen, weil du hast ja gerade gesagt, ich würde interessieren, was die Leute da so haben wollen. Solltet ihr diese Sendung beispielsweise als Podcast hören, weil ihr heute schlant, schlant grölend auf dem Kuhnam steht, und dass ihr auf dem Stau rauskommt, könnt ihr euch natürlich auch gerne melden. Ihr schreibt eine Mail an mail-at ccc.de. Und wenn es da noch Anmerkungen gibt, dann können wir da irgendwie gerne noch in irgendeiner Form darauf eingehen. Wie ist das eigentlich mit, wir haben jetzt über viele verschiedene Browser gesprochen und die Entwicklung und so weiter und so fort. Gibt es so den ultimativen Browser, weil ich kann ja als Windows, also als PC-User, mir auch einen Safari ziehen, der eigentlich für einen Mac gedacht ist, und ich kann auf einen Mac mehr aber auch einen Firefox und einen Internet-Explorer ziehen und den da quasi benutzen. Es ist jetzt nicht mehr so, dass jedes einzelne System seinen speziellen Browser hat. Gibt es da so aus eurer Sicht die ultimative oder perfekte Maschine?
Du könntest schon mal sagen, welches nicht sind.
Also Internet-Explorer, wie ich ihn liebevoll nenne, ist natürlich irgendwie bei mir zumindest die allerletzte, weil es bereitet einem Web-Entwickler einfach konstant Schmerzen, eine Webseite zu bauen, die auf dem Internet-Explorer genauso aussieht wie auf dem Firefox oder dem Safari. Abgesehen davon gibt es auch Unterschiede zwischen Safari und Firefox. Wie gesagt, ich persönlich bin jetzt auf Firefox und Safari festgefahren. Ich benutze eigentlich kaum große Features von den Browsern, habe auch kaum Plugins installiert, außer an Adblocker. Ich benutze den hauptsächlich zum Brausen und zum Web-Entwicklern. Der Firefox hat zum Beispiel für Web-Entwickler ein paar mehr Features. Der Safari ist einfach ein bisschen schlanker und schneller. Wenn ich irgendwie brause, brause ich mit Safari. Wenn ich Web-Entwickle, nehme ich Firefox. So ist irgendwie bei mir die Aufteilung. Die können beide extrem viel. Die sind ganz weit vorne mit der Implementation von Standards und Features. Die sind mittlerweile auch einigermaßen stable. Und Firefox 3 fühlt sich jetzt auch zum Beispiel eigentlich ganz gut an. Also ich hatte bis jetzt noch keine Probleme. Ich höre jetzt immer so von anderen, dass der instabil wäre oder irgendwelche Sachen ausgehen.
Ich habe eher ein Problem, dass ich habe so eine RSS-Line oben im Browser und die aktualisiert sich seit einer Woche nicht. Das ist ein bisschen doof, wenn du echt denkst, du hast alle News mal da.
Aber darum, das ist auch so eine Sache, da bin ich irgendwie plugins. Das wäre auch ein bisschen skeptisch.
Also Flash vielleicht noch, aber das war es dann auch.
Also ich bin da relativ emotionslos auch ehrlich gesagt. Also ich habe für mich rausgefunden, Firefox und Safari, also die Engines darunter, das ist ja WebKit und Gecko. Die sind halt in vielen anderen Browsern auch drin. Sind einfach wahrscheinlich schon ziemlich weit verbreitet ja. Und Internet Explorer läuft auf Mac sowieso nicht. Habe ich nur in der VM, im Windows, wenn ich mal was testen muss. Und von daher gibt es da jetzt erstmal nichts anderes. Opera gibt es auch so ein paar Fans. Der ist auf jeden Fall auch nicht schlecht. Ist auch mit Standardzeit vorne, aber irgendwie hier in unseren Breitengraden nicht so populär.
Auf Mobiltelefonen, also wer ein Nokia-Telefon hatte, die neuere Serie, da sind ja irgendwie auch Browser drauf. Da ist sogar irgendwie in einem eingebauten, ist auch glaube ich ein Webkit-Renderer. Aber dafür ist der Rest von dem Ding irgendwie extrem schnarchend langsam und macht dann auch nicht wirklich Spaß.
Aber auf Mobiltelefonen hat man auch nicht so richtig die Wahl, welchen Browser. Also noch nicht.
Naja, Opera gibt es, Opera Mini. Und der ist zumindestens von einer Browsing Experience sozusagen, also von wie man das Ding benutzt, deutlich angenehmer als jetzt der eingebaute.
Gibt es jetzt irgendwelche Dinge, die wir ganz groß nicht besprochen haben, die wir jetzt noch reinmüssen, weil ansonsten würde ich das Schiff langsam in den Hafen steuern. Wir haben nämlich noch einen Kollegen auf dem Kuhdamm zu stehen, der da mitten im Irrsinn ist.
Ja, ich würde vielleicht nochmal kurz meine Lieblingsweb-Applikation oder die, die ich am tollsten finde, ist eigentlich Flickr. Weil Flickr, also das sind eigentlich auch sowieso die Web-Applikationen, die ich für sinnvoll achte, die dir eigentlich Möglichkeiten bieten, die du auf dem Desktop einfach nicht hast. Und das sind eben diese Verlinkungen, also dass du irgendwie andere Kontexte mit einbeziehen kannst. Du kannst halt ein Foto bei Flickr hochladen. Du kannst das auf einer Map positionieren und den Geokoordinaten geben. Das heißt, bei Google Earth, wenn du auf irgendwie die Position brauchst, kriegst du das Foto von mir von Flickr da rein geladen. Du kannst irgendwie Fotos ziemlich gut suchen, weil die halt gut getaggt sind. Die sind semantisch miteinander irgendwie verwoben und so weiter. Und irgendwie auch so dieses Business-Modell irgendwie. Du kannst einen Account gratis haben und Bilder hochladen. Und wenn du halt irgendwie unlimited space hast, dann zahlst du irgendwie 24 Dollar im Jahr. Voll okay. Und das ist wirklich eine ziemlich nützliche Web-Applikation. Und das ist so das, was ich eigentlich dann im Web als Applikation benutze. Die Features bieten, die es so auf dem Desktop nicht gibt. Ich kann in meinem iPhoto oder wo auch immer nicht sagen, ich positioniere das auf einer Karte und ich share das mit dem und so weiter und so fort. Also zum Beispiel auf Flickr, wenn ich da ein Foto hochlade, kann es einfach passieren, dass die Zeit mich fragt, ob sie das in ihrer Zeitung veröffentlicht. Das ist schon ein paar Mal passiert. Auch im Reiseführer ist ein Foto von mir drin. Du lätst ein Foto hoch, du kriegst ein paar Tage später eine Nachricht und können wir das veröffentlichen? Ja.
Aber bezahlst du dafür nicht, oder?
Doch es gibt auch Leute, die dafür bezahlen tatsächlich. Also sie fragen und manchmal bezahlen sie auch dafür. Das ist auch voll okay. Aber Flickr funktioniert einfach. In dem Sinne sehe ich eigentlich auch Web-Applikationen, die wirklich Sinn machen.
Chaos Radio 136 war das mit Huckel und mit Frank. Vielen Dank euch beiden. Das war eine sehr amüsante Sendung mit einigen neuen Dingen, die wir lernen konnten.
Wir haben den Fußball getrotzt.
Wir haben den Fußball getrotzt, wir haben das Spiel begleitet. Wir hatten ein paar Anrufer und wir hatten auch eine Menge Fragen, die hier noch per Mail reinkamen. Ihr könnt wie gesagt die Sendung gerne nochmal hören. Gibt es als Podcast, könnt ihr euch ziehen. Chaosradio.ccc.de ist The Lost Website Lost. Wir hören uns wieder in vier Wochen im Ende Juli. Chaos Radio am letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Euch beiden herzlichen Dank. Den letzten Song, den kriegt Huckel, den hat er sich ausgesucht. Mister Bob Dylan, The Man in Me.